yesterday Kanye West was on CNBC to talk
about the breakup between Yeezy and the
Gap and oh boy did he not disappoint
Kanye West kept laying down line after
line after line and it is very obvious
that he's either a genius or he's crazy
here was Kanye's appearance on the
national business show so it's hard to
interrupt I just while we have you you
know we're we're showing the stock right
now of Gap and Adidas and they're
they're
on that news and in general it's been a
struggling retailer they lost the CEO
Sonia singal the one who you I believe
made the deal with to begin with and
they're trying to stabilize the overall
business you've always liked this
company and you talked about how you
hired high hopes for for the partnership
do you think that Gap can ever sort of
regain it's cool again and and yeah
they only have one opportunity to be
able to be a big player what do you
think it is
I feel like you're not happy with them
today so
and they have one individual on the
planet that could save the gap
and as an individual
uh
uh sometimes the answer is sitting right
in front of you
well there there was a lot of potential
in this deal but it sounds like you're
you're terminating
well don't don't bring a leader in and
have them that lead wow you know why
would I argue with people who are
getting paid by the guy I'm sorry you
know I'm not going to argue with people
that are Broker Than me about money
I understood
yeah we think we thank you for the time
today and for joining us on the show
all right
there we go on one hand you have to look
at Kanye's appearance yesterday and you
got to kind of laugh and say damn that
was entertaining on the other hand
though you gotta say Kanye West
understands his value and he realizes
that he not only can turn around the Gap
he realizes that he can dictate terms in
these business deals Kanye West used to
be a nobody and then he began to build a
little audience as a music producer and
then eventually burst onto the scene as
a musician but we have seen musician
after musician come and go Kanye has had
staying power though because he
understands how to be a business owner
not just a performer Kanye West is a
multi-billionaire and he continues to
grow his Empire because he stays true to
exactly what he wants to do it takes a
lot of courage to go on national
television and some cool sunglasses and
say I'm not arguing with anyone poorer
than me but it also takes that same
courage to walk into the boardroom of
one of the largest retailers in America
and say I am the only person in this
country that can turn your company
around the Gap is either making a
massive mistake or they're dodging a
bullet it'll take a couple of years
until we find out which one just
happened